chuckle can you talk about fear of
failure in how to overcome it fear of
failure
so obviously fear of failure can can
keep you from taking risk and it can
leave you just sitting there paralyzed
into not taking any action at all and
obviously that's bad but I don't
actually want you to overcome the fear
of failure I want I want you to be
afraid of failure fear of failure is
good fear of failure will keep you up at
night planning and rehearsing and going
over contingencies fear of failure will
keep you training hard it'll stop you
from cutting corners fear fear of
failure will keep you working and
thinking and striving and relentlessly
trying to be more prepared for battle
so I want you to be afraid of failing
I fear failure but more important I want
you to be horrified I want you to be
terrified of sitting on your ass and
doing nothing that is what I want you to
be afraid of of waking up in six days or
six weeks or six years or sixty years in
being no closer to your goal you've made
no progress that
is the horror that is the nightmare that
is what you need to be truly afraid of
being stagnant so get up and go take the
risk take the gamble take the first step
take action and don't let another day
slip by